في شارع وسط سنفرو بول قوات ملثمه بملابس
عسكريه تصادر معدات من محطه تلفزيونيه حيث
ان صحفيا بلغاريا كان يصور عبر الطريق
عندما تم رصده فجاه وخلال ثواني وضع ارضا
مع تصويب مسدس الى راسه ليتم استهداف
مساعده بعد ذلك المسلحون اخذوا هواتفهم
كاميراتهم قبل الهروب بداخل مركبه هذا
الهجوم الجريء التقط عبر كاميرا مراقبه
لكن لن يتم اجراء اي
تحقيقات الحكومه التي نصبت نفسها هنا
والتي توالي النظام الروسي يبدو انها تعمل
بالتنسيق مع القوات الروسيه حيث يتم تضييق
الخناق على المعارضه ورغم انها تسيطر على
القرم منذ اسبوعين الا انها اغلقت محطتي
تلفزيون اوكرانيين وتم استبدال واحده منها
بالتلفزيون الروسي ومع محاوله تشديد
قبضتها على وسائل الاعلام فان الكثير من
الصحفيين يعتبرون سلطه القرم الجديده مصدر
قلق بالغ
لهم وتحديا للظروف البائسه قام مئتا شخص
موال للحكومه الاوكرانيه بمعارض الاستفتاء
قبل اسبوع واحد فقط من اقامته والذي قد
يقرر ما اذا كان قرم ستنفصل وتنضم الى
روسيا هذه السيده تقول ان ما يفعلونه غير
قانوني فقرم جزء من اوكرانيا والمجتمع
الدولي لا يقوم بحمايه
القاده في كيف بجانب قاده الغرب يعتبرون
الاستفتاء غير قانوني كذلك حكومه القرم
تقول انه تم دعوه المراقبين الدوليين
للاشراف على الانتخابات لكن ليس مستغربا
ان اغلب الاصوات ستاتي من
روسيا ومن الواضح ان هؤلاء المراقبين لم
يكن مرحبا بهم في نقطه التفتيش هذه
بالقرن بينما تم منع دخول مراقبي منظمه
الامن والتعاون في اوروبا الى المنطقه في
حين ان الحكومه الاوكرانيه تريد منهم
التحقيق في احتلال القوات الروسيه للقرم
لكن يبدو ان ذلك لن يحدث في الوقت الراهن
على
الاقل